très bien chers amis la primaire de la
droite et du centre est un superbe
succès un succès populaire par sa
participation
un succès par le respect qui a régné
entre les candidats et surtout un succès
par la qualité des propositions
ce soir je suis fier de l'image qui a
été donnée par notre famille politique
je veux remercier les bénévoles les élus
les cadres et les militants républicains
qui se sont mobilisés depuis des
semaines pour assurer la réussite de ce
scrutin
je félicite chaleureusement françois
fillon dans la victoire incontestable
vient récompenser la constance la
volonté jamais démentie de dire la
vérité
c'est la preuve que les français peuvent
soutenir un projet bâti autour de
propositions claires et fortes
je veux rendre hommage à alain juppé qui
a défendu jusqu'au bout ses idées avec
dignité et hauteur de vue la politique
peut être dur mais je veux lui dire
qu'il reste évidemment une figure de
référence pour toute notre famille
politique j'ai enfin une pensée toute
particulière pour nicolas sarkozy et
ceux qui l'ont soutenu dimanche dernier
il a forcé notre respect par son
élégance et sa volonté de privilégier
avant tout l'intérêt de notre famille
politique est de la france ce soir c'est
une première étape
une très belle première étape mais ce
n'est pas un aboutissement
c'est un commencement il reste deux
tours pour tourner la page du socialisme
et il faut se tourner maintenant vers
l'ensemble des français la victoire de
la droite et du centre
elle nous en sommes convaincus
nécessaire pour le redressement de notre
pays mais elle n'est pas acquise et elle
dépendra de deux conditions
la première c'est le rassemblement
françois fillon tout au long de sa
campagne
et encore ce soir a insisté sur sa
volonté d'union
chacun devra faire les gestes pour que
la primaire ne laisse pas de blessures
dans les responsabilités qui sont les
miennes
avec notre équipe j oserais pleinement
et j'invite tous les élus des
républicains à s'engager dès ce soir
autour de françois fillon la seconde
condition c'est de continuer à porter
une parole claire et de défendre nos
convictions avec une détermination
totale
le message des électeurs est limpide ils
ne veulent pas d'une droite qui en
disent moins ils veulent une droite qui
en fasse plus ce soit en l'espoir
s'élever de pouvoir tourner enfin la
page d'un quinquennat qui a été si dur
pour les français c'est une vraie
alternance que nous avons le devoir de
proposer
vive la république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]